[Music]
Disney's hit show Jesse aired for four
years before the spin-off bunk'd took
over a lot has changed in this time and
the actors of jesse have grown up before
our eyes
did you know debby ryan has admitted to
having a crush on a former co-star is
there drama going on between sky and
Debbie make sure you keep watching until
the end some of the transformation
pictures may shock you if this is your
first time visiting this channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you the cast of Jesse before and
after
Peyton lists Peyton list is one
in-demand actress she won our hearts on
Jessie as Emma Ross and we've continued
watching her as Emma on bunked the kind
and sometimes ditzy Emma is the oldest
of the Ross kids and the only biological
child to mr. and mrs. Ross in real life
Peyton has quite the resume she was only
four years old when she first started
acting in the soap opera as the world
turns
since then she has acted in dozens of
roles including 27 dresses Diary of a
Wimpy Kid and the thinning it looks like
she has some upcoming projects as well
so you'll want to be on alert for that
one of the upcoming projects includes a
movie called departures where she'll be
starring alongside Nina Dobrev and
Maisie Williams apparently Peyton is not
the only actor in the family she has two
brothers who also act including her twin
brother Spencer fun fact she's actually
one minute older than Spencer Spencer
has actually appeared in bunked before
as a character named Eric do you
remember seeing him that would be fun
getting to work with your brother
although Spencer is pretty popular he's
nowhere near as popular as Peyton she
has over million followers that's way
more than any of our other Jessie Co
stars including Debbie she's got quite
the fan base hopefully this means we'll
be seeing her a lot in the future
Kevin Chamberlain Kevin Chamberlain
plays Bertram Winkle the Ross family
Butler as a butler he is lazy and
grouchy you don't often see him actually
doing work but he makes sure to look
busy when the Ross parents are home even
though he calls the Ross children nanny
killers he still loves and cares about
them but the same can't be said about
Jessie we're sure they secretly like
each other but Bertram and Jessie aren't
often shown getting along Bertram spends
a lot of his time reading magazines and
watching TV sounds like our kind of job
in real life
Kevin Chamberlain is a successful
Broadway actor IMDB says that he is one
of the few Broadway actors who have been
nominated for a Tony Award in three
for acting categories he was nominated
for Best Actor in a play Best Actor in a
Musical and Best Featured actor in a
musical even though he is a well
respected Broadway actor he has been
acting on TV since 1991 when Jesse
finally ended kevin wrote a heartfelt
goodbye poem to his fans his poem reads
for years hundreds of stories thousands
of script pages tens of thousands of
rehearsal hours millions of laughs he
said they taught him how to be a kid and
be silly again and they taught him how
to dougie he says he will miss Bertram
we will definitely miss him too
Karen Brar Karen Brar plays Ravi Ross in
Jesse and bunked he was adopted by the
Ross parents from India his first
language is Hindi but he is fluent in
English when he was adopted he brought
his pet lizard mr. Kipling we find out
later that mr. Kipling is a girl so her
name changes to mrs. Kipling talk about
confusing in real life Karen has starred
in many different roles including the
Diary of a Wimpy Kid movies actually
Karen and Peyton knew each other before
Jessie because they work together on
Diary of a Wimpy Kid and they continued
to work together on bunked in an
interview
Karen confessed that his dream co-star
is Jennifer Lawrence we like his taste
in co-stars can you imagine how funny
the two of them would be together Karen
is probably one of the jesse stars that
has changed the most over the course of
the show when he started working on
Jessie he was only 11 and now he is a
young adult his before and after
pictures look quite different if you
want to see even more pictures head to
his Instagram account
we were really digging his style not to
mention his face with 3 million
followers we're guessing we have some
competition we also found out he's a
mama's boy he admitted in an interview
that his mom is the person he texts the
most how nice is that
Chris Scalia Tony is the doorman of the
Ross's building and Jessie he is
handsome and has a New York accent he
also has a crush on Jessie and wants to
date her and although it takes him a few
tries they do end up going on dates
eventually tony has a strange talent for
playing the kazoo maybe one day he'll
make it as a famous kazoo player what do
you think Tony is played by Chris Galya
in an interview Chris said he loved
working on the set of Jessie saying that
the rest of the cast is a ton of fun he
says they are always laughing and
pulling pranks on each other in addition
to acting chris is a model and has a
great singing voice if you want to see
some drool-worthy pictures of Chris
check out his Instagram he has a ton of
model snaps on there we're hoping to see
him in another role soon where he'll
singing maybe a musical in an interview
he went on about his co-star Debbie Ryan
saying that she's funny welcoming and
has a great personality it sounds to us
like Chris might have a little crush on
Debbie
Chris mentions that Jesse was his first
big acting job hopefully jesse has
opened some doors for future roles
because we need to see more of Chris
Christina more
Christina Ross is the mother of the Ross
children she's an actress and supermodel
and is married to Morgan who is a famous
movie director
Christina loves her children very much
but it's not around often because of her
and her husband's jobs even though
neither of them is around much we're
still happy that they clearly love their
children when they see them her only
biological child of the four is Emma the
rest of her children are adopted fun
fact she was very young when she had
Emma she was 19
perhaps that's the reason her and Morgan
decided to adopt the rest of their kids
her and Morgan met at camp kikiwaka
which is the camp Emma Ravi and Zuri go
to in bunked Christina and Morgan are
supposed to parody Angelina Jolie and
Brad Pitt
they are both famous in Hollywood and
have adopted many of their children but
do have biological children
Christina Moore is the actress who plays
Christina Ross she is an actress
comedian fashion designer model and
screenwriter she has been acting since
1996 and starred in some very notable
roles including That 70's Show without a
paddle and True Blood unfortunately we
didn't see too much of Christina and
Jessi but we are hoping that there is
the opportunity to see more of her
Charles esten
Charles esten plays Morgan Ross on
Jessie he is the father of Emma
Zuri Luke and Robbie he is married to
Christina and is a film director known
for his movies galactopus although
Morgan is not around much for his kids
he loves them and would do a lot for
them for example in the very first
episode of Jessie we get introduced to
the characters and get a taste of their
personalities the audience sees that the
parents are not around much and that
there is usually a nanny around to take
care of the kid Morgan and Christina
promise to come home to see Emma's
science project presentation but then
they tell her over video chat that they
won't be able to make it however when
Jessie tells Morgan and Christina how
upset emma is they come home to see her
presentation this is just one example of
how the parents prove their love for
their children Charles who plays Morgan
has been acting for many years currently
he has a lead role on Nashville
and has been on the show since 2012 the
show has been nominated for and won many
awards including the People's Choice
Award and Teen Choice Award Christina
Mora has
one guest our appearance in bunked so
far so we're hoping that Morgan Ross
will make an appearance to JJ toda JJ
toda has a recurring role on Jesse as
Stuart Wooten when he is first
introduced to us he had just moved next
door to the Ross family and felt
instantly in love with Zuri throughout
his time on Jessie he tries his hardest
to win Zuri's heart in real life JJ is
an actor comedian singer and writer only
a teenager he has quite the resume in
addition to Jessie he has been in glee
Sofia the first Liv and Maddie and
spider-man homecoming even before he
started acting on TV he did theater and
even started a YouTube channel at the
age of six he currently has over seven
thousand followers on his YouTube
account where he does mostly comedy
sketches in spider-man homecoming JJ got
to work alongside some pretty cool
people including Tom Holland Michael
Keaton Robert Downey jr. Gweneth Paltrow
and zendaya in an interview JJ had many
nice things to say about zendaya
they sound like they could be really
good friends actually we wish we could
be friends with JJ in his interviews he
seems like a very kind chatty and
outgoing person he doesn't seem to be
very shy and speaks his mind what a
great way to be we can't wait to see him
and the rest of the cast in spider-man
and see what else he gets to do in the
future
Cameron Boyce Cameron Boyce plays Luke
Ross on Jessie Lucas one of the Rosses
adopted children but unlike Sir Ian Ravi
he was adopted from the United States he
was adopted from Detroit when he was
four years old
Luke is portrayed as mischievous
sarcastic cool and athletic
unfortunately he doesn't always do great
with his schoolwork maybe it would help
if he didn't have so many distractions
at home specifically maybe if his crush
wasn't also his nanny do you think Luke
actually has a crush on Jessie or do you
think that he's purposely trying to
annoy her sounds like something Luke
would do Cameron Boyce is the actor who
plays Luke and he is quite well known
for a number of his roles outside of
Jessie he was in grown ups 1 and 2 jake
and the neverland pirates
gamers guide to pretty much anything and
descendants 1 & 2 these roles have
caught him a lot of attention his acting
skills are well recognized as well as
his unique look
he has curly black hair and his face is
sprinkled with freckles from the look of
his Instagram account he does some
acting as well which really doesn't
surprise us he's got a great face for
the camera it's hard to believe that
just a few years ago he was playing
annoying but cute Luke when today he
seemed so mature
Debu Ryan jesse is played by Debbie
she has been acting in Disney shows
since 2008 when she was 14
debbie kept her same look throughout
most of her time acting on Disney and
has only really changed in the last few
years until recently she was known for
her cute look of either a thinned out
fringe or a side-swept bang today her
bangs appear to be grown out and she
opts for a Messier tousled hair style in
addition to her hairstyle she of course
has grown up to her Instagram pictures
display a more rebellious and
fashion-forward woman we like the change
speaking of things that change we've
heard rumors that her friendship with
co-star Skye Jackson has changed as well
unfortunately Skye alleged that Debbie
has bullied her Debbie came back saying
this was not true and suggested that a
specific co-stars parents assumingly
referring to Skye's parents were hard to
deal with talk about drama
however Debbie doesn't seem to have
issues with all her co-stars her and :
dylan sprouse starred in the suite life
on deck together from 2008 to 2011 and
she appears to still be super close with
cult today she's appeared in numerous
pictures with him as she supports his
new show Riverdale in an interview she
admits to the reporter that she used to
have a crush on one of the Sprouse twins
even though she never admitted who it
was wouldn't hurt Cole make a great
couple
Skye Jackson Skye Jackson plays Zuri
Ross on Jessie and she is the absolute
cutest we're happy that we've been able
to follow her from Jessie to bunk'd we
love her as clever and witty Zuri and we
love her even more in real life
Skye's look isn't the only thing that
has been shirred over the years but her
personality as well she recently worked
with dosomething.org to help young
people build up their self-esteem and
tackle problems with bullying speaking
of bullying there have been tons of
rumors going around that Skye was being
bullied by debby ryan on set this would
be really upsetting considering how much
we like both of them they seemed like
such good friends before a fan tweeted
Skye asking her why she is rude to Debby
Skye tweeted back that she's not rude to
her and in fact it's the other way
around this fueled the rumors and Debby
eventually replied to a question about
the accusations of bullying by saying
that they weren't true Debbie also
implied that Skye's parents were causing
trouble that's not good we hope
everything has been resolved speaking of
Skye's parents we found an interview
with Skye's mom where she talks about
how much Skye loves acting but she says
that Skye gets overwhelmed with fans
sometimes her mom also admitted that
Skye really looks up to Rihanna who
doesn't
are there any other Disney TV stars
who've you've noticed have changed a lot
over the course of their careers let us
know in the comments below we love
hearing from you
[Music]